[Music]
with her trademark bob and dark
sunglasses anna winter rules the 300
billion american fashion universe anna
is the single most influential
individual
in the world of fashion
as editor of vogue magazine she's become
a celebrity herself
with a reputation as fairy godmother to
some anna winter's approval is important
anything i do and fire breathing dragon
to others i've heard names ice queen
nuclear winter i'm sure she's demanding
to get results you do have to be
demanding is she warm and fuzzy no
why should she have to be
her influence has moved beyond the pages
of the glossy magazine
she's a pacesetter
and power broker
she is the woman that brought fashion
to big business and to the world
globally
[Music]
i i don't know anything about uh fashion
and i don't read vogue regularly but i
know a lot about you vogue editor anna
winter confronted her storied reputation
head-on in a rare late-night television
appearance i read in the new york times
this week that i'm an ice queen
i'm the sun king
i'm an alien fleeing from district 9 and
i'm a dominatrix
so i reckon that makes me
a lukewarm royalty with a whip
from outer space what do you think good
gig
[Applause]
[Music]
her gig is editor-in-chief of vogue
magazine
for 22 years the powerful and
intimidating queen bee has told women
what and who to wear
long skirts are short royal blue or navy
or that gray is the new black i adore
fashion i adore what it says about women
vogue has a recognition that no other
magazine has and that it's deeply
satisfying to me and is revolutionary
she's
she revolutionized the whole
modern fashion industry
anna is someone who responds to
competitiveness in a way that you wish
everyone did she doesn't get angry she
gets even
winter manages her media profile
carefully and declined to participate in
this program
[Music]
anna winter was ambitious from a young
age
born in london in 1949
she dropped out of school it was the 60s
and she was captivated by london's
cultural and social scene
her mother eleanor was american and her
british father charles was the
hard-nosed editor-in-chief of the london
newspaper the evening standard
lori schechter began her career as anna
winter's assistant
she grew up in a home with a journalist
a newsman
there's a certain standard and rigor of
work there
that definitely got passed on to her and
is the way she approaches everything
that she does now
when she was 20 winter got her
well-dressed foot in the door at the
newly formed british magazine harpers
and queen
she was intensely competitive she angled
to work with the best photographers to
climb up the ladder
but after five years at harper's and
queen she was passed over for the
position of editor-in-chief
she left the magazine and england and in
1975 headed to new york's seventh avenue
vera wang sits on top of her own fashion
empire and has known winter for over 30
years
she was not
anna winter high priestess of vogue
she was my friend and we were two girls
that were looking
to get something going in the fashion
industry and anna was definitely
set about
going to the magazine business and and
particularly vogue
but vogue would have to wait
winter's first job in new york was at
harper's bazaar
she was fired for being as she claimed
in a newspaper interview
to european
after a few months without work she
accepted a job offer from penthouse
magazine publisher bob guccione as
fashion editor at viva an erotic
magazine for women
her fashion layouts won recognition
a few years later she landed her first
big job
fashion editor at new york magazine
she was a complete mystery fascinating
mystery
she wore the dark glasses pretty much
100 percent of the time
it is sink or swim
she tells you what she wants and she's
not going to tell you how to do it i
lost eight pounds in two weeks and it's
just because it was constant
winter was building a reputation for
stylish layouts and a relentless work
ethic
she had a very set agenda
she has had the courage
and the guts and the intelligence and
the energy to do all of this
it wasn't long before the executives at
conde nast cy new house and alexander
lieberman took notice
tom florio was the publishing director
at vogue and has known winter for 30
years in those early days of conde nast
it almost felt like a young hollywood
studio you know and mr newhouse with
alex just had this great sense of how to
build
not only magazines but personalities to
lead these magazines the organization
really embraced people with vision and
determination and drive
no one had more of that drive than anna
winter she was rewarded with a job at
vogue created just for her
it wasn't the job she was aiming for
that was already taken by long-time
editor-in-chief grace mirabella there
was obviously resistance but when anna
comes in she's not a wallflower
and she's going to make her point of
view known and that's why she was
brought there
winter's point of view was not welcomed
by mirabella
in her autobiography mirabella described
the new creative director as cold and
suspicious
always working against her to undermine
her authority
she wrote that she felt winter was being
groomed for her job
i think there were those who felt
threatened
they didn't know her they didn't know
quite why she was there
and they weren't going to necessarily
welcome
anyone new
let alone someone like anna who
cut quite a striking figure
caught your eye
and definitely had the attention of
the major decision makers that come in
asked
[Music]
after a three-year power struggle conde
nast put an ocean between them they
offered winter a promotion to
editor-in-chief of british vogue
moving up the corporate ladder brought
new excitement but it came at a tough
personal cost
she moved to london with her new baby
while her husband stayed behind in new
york anna winter arrived in london in
1986 and immediately began to alter the
shape of british vogue in some ways she
brought it more down to earth for those
who wanted to maybe actually find things
that they could buy
and made it more serviceable for the
reader
the readers may have enjoyed the change
but her staff was not as accepting they
gave her a nickname that stuck nuclear
winter it's a little bit the greta garbo
thing if you
don't say a lot and don't sort of engage
people but that you know then leaves the
rest of the world to make up what they
think is the truth
is she warm and fuzzy you know
no
why should she have to be is she someone
you'd like her opinion absolutely after
18 months conde nast brought their
up-and-coming star back to new york to
overhaul their shelter magazine house
and garden
[Music]
winter changed the title to hg
out were photos of empty rooms in were
lavish spreads of celebrities in their
homes
readers revolted and the magazine was
forced to hand out subscription refunds
terry agains is a former senior fashion
writer for the wall street journal and
the author of the end of fashion i mean
that's why i call anna revolutionary
because i mean even her plan to like
come in and do something that radical to
a
uh an established magazine the
prospect for failure is high when you do
something that
that gutsy
these failures would have ended many a
career but not anna winters
conde nast still had other plans for her
it was the worst kept secret in the
fashion world there have been rumors
that miss wintour would become the
editor of american vogue replacing the
veteran grace mirabella well now the hot
publishing story is that this probably
will happen
after 17 years mirabella was out
38 year old anna winter got the job she
always wanted
her vision was clear from her first
cover she paired a ten thousand dollar
top with forty dollar jeans that
signaled something new revolutionary
this was a new editor she was british
she was stylish she was young and you
know and she really had a point of view
we knew that this was going to be a new
era
in a december 1988 interview winter
explained what it takes to be
editor-in-chief of vogue that i think is
what's so important in in this job is to
have the right kind of instinct and gut
reaction to
produce a magazine that is
of the moment that just captures what's
going on
right now i mean that's what it is to be
in vogue
[Music]
mirabella's traditional head shots were
replaced with winter's fresh new look
she spared no expense on elaborate photo
shoots with the best photographers
[Music]
anna knew just how to balance
our desire for escape
and for beauty and for real fashion with
our need to have things that are
relevant to us as women things that fit
into our lifestyle and who we are and
where we've come
once again winter saw the allure of
celebrities and replaced supermodels
with superstars on the cover
filmmaker rj cutler very early on anna
wintour saw
that celebrity
power
global industry and fashion were all
coming together we had the mega brands
gucci prada lvmh working women became
executive women
and so they needed power suits for work
she understood the glamour
of high fashion
the desire to make people dream
to aspire to inspire but she also
understood how fashion as a business had
changed
[Music]
winter's growing reputation captured
increased advertising dollars
ed nardoza is the editor of women's wear
daily the advertising business can be
very fickle you have to build
loyalty over time you have to provide
real value and reasons for advertisers
to consistently stay in your
publications because it is one of the
most competitive industries in the world
in 10 years ad revenues climbed from
just over 87 million dollars to nearly
150 million dollars
vogue's success brought winter increased
power
her front row appearances at fashion
shows wearing her trademark dark glasses
took on new meaning
every glacial expression was scanned for
clues
and became someone very important to
have at your show
when she's there it validates the show
that the show was cool that means that
the show is like a big deal
vogue under winter was on a journey from
magazine to brand
success brought winter increased public
scrutiny in 1999 the tabloids ran with
the story of her divorce and her
relationship with millionaire texas
communications executive shelby bryan
people gossip and and speculate about
her every move but she has just
basically risen above it
and i think it's a smart thing to do
undistracted winter was focusing her
attention on what was ahead for vogue
her answer was invariably the same
people are always asking what was that
your favorite collection was that your
favorite issue and it to me it's always
the next one it's the it's the idea of
what is to come it's always the future
always the future
most editors don't think beyond their
title but anna thinks about the world
and how it impacts the title and also
how the title can impact the world
charles townsend is the ceo of conde
nast publications she's involved in all
aspects of the globe brand whether it's
marketing the brand to the consumer
whether it's marketing the brand to the
advertising community
you know it's political influence it's
social influence she manages
that brand's positioning across all of
those parameters
to extend the brand in 2003 she launched
teen vogue
men's vogue and vogue living followed
in one year ad revenue for men's vogue
dropped over 1 million dollars
in 2008 conde nast cut it to an
occasional supplement
u.s vogue living disappeared
only teen vogue survived on the
newsstands
the brand extension didn't quite work
but those were natural and productive
experiments
she takes risks
she works really really hard and when
life doesn't work she's she brushes it
off and she recovers and just
tries to learn from the situation and
move on
[Applause]
[Music]
winter's increased visibility and her
public support of the fur industry
attracted some wild confrontations
during the height of the anti-firm
movement you know anna was defined she
was wearing her furs
the protesters would show up at the
shows
she was having lunch at the four seasons
and someone put a dead animal in her
plate
if you're walking through paris and
somebody hits you with a pie and knocks
you down that's pretty aggressive
anybody else would have been upset she
stood up wiped her face she said this is
getting really boring went back to the
hotel changed and made her next meeting
after that she started to get protection
she comes into the show
and she's accompanied by these two
bodyguards
this also helps stoke the myth that
she's you know in a class by herself
she dug in her stylish stilettos never
wavering in her support for the
multi-billion dollar fur industry
the more her reputation grew the more
unwelcome attention she got the novel
the devil wears prada was considered by
many in the fashion industry to be a
thinly disguised and devastating
portrayal of winter
the hollywood version starring meryl
streep was a huge hit grossing over 326
million dollars in theaters worldwide
give me that little table that i like at
that store
get us a reservation for dinner tonight
at that place
[Music]
this dragon lady reputation or is often
portrayed i think there's some kind of
gender issue here because she's a woman
people expect her to behave a certain
way
and i think if she were a ceo running a
company there would be no issue
[Music]
winter was now a recognized power broker
with wide-reaching relationships
throughout the fashion industry
she's been very instrumental in many of
the very large brands when they were
looking for
a standard bearer or creator or a
designer or a creative director
she has been instrumental in helping
those brands succeed as well
[Music]
one brand that needed her help was gap
for years the company had been suffering
from declining sales they consulted
winter and she recommended young
designer patrick robinson so i think she
called me and that's just what my
thoughts were and sort of gave me some
thoughts about what the job sort of
could look like more from how she saw it
and just as a per it was more personal
so it was that simple but she was this
great sounding board for me when i was
thinking about the job
her matchmaking worked
in 2007 robinson became gap's new
executive vice president of design anna
winter's approval is important anything
i do it still is
she's the first steel to this day that
sees everything i do
but after four years of lackluster
results the gap dismissed its star
designer
winter's interest in supporting new
talent led her to create the vogue
fashion fund to provide grants and
business advice you have to keep that
feeder system going anna was really
interested in making certain we continue
to have more designers which means more
advertisers and more sales so all this
works together
everything came together in september
2007 when winter delivered the fall
season premiere issue of vogue
the magazine had a record-breaking 727
pages of advertising
is anyone coming to this run through
except for me
it became the subject of the hit
documentary the september issue a rare
look inside vogue the order
[Music]
looks like now for blind people
dana does not look back she looks
forward she does not doubt she trusts
herself she requires a thick skin but
you know even a thick skin has nerves
under it she would need steel nerves in
2009 we found ourselves facing economic
circumstances through the recession that
we never imagined were possible
[Music]
in 2009 the deepest recession in decades
was forcing business to slash
advertising dollars
vogue's ad sales for the all-important
september issue plunged from 727 pages
in 2007 to 429 in 2009
conde nast is a private company that
does not publicly report financial
results
clearly the company was under pressure
they shuttered six of their magazines
and cut hundreds of jobs but their crown
jewel vogue managed its costs and
managed to escape drastic cuts
seventh avenue was also being squeezed
by a shopping slowdown winter took on a
new mission
new yorkers you're always in fashion
always in fashion her idea was a
worldwide retail extravaganza called
fashion's night out entire fashion
industry is counting on you
thank you for coming out tonight it
turned out
that this was an unprecedented event
that brought together over a thousand
retailers around the world
and thousands and thousands of consumers
flooded the stores
[Music]
it was so successful that it has become
an annual event
[Applause]
winter also stepped in to save one of
new york city's treasures the costume
institute at the metropolitan museum of
art
as fundraiser in chief she hosts the
annual gala
it was something that rivaled even the
oscars
emily rafferty is president of the
metropolitan museum of art this last
year we raised in one night uh through
her leadership over nine million dollars
even in a time of recession
there are other formidable challenges in
front of winter
conde nast has admittedly been slow to
adapt to the digital age
now vogue and winter's future depend on
it
any monthly magazine
really needs to examine that there's
demand
for immediate information how do you
supply that demand
her monthly magazine faces increasing
competition from bloggers and
interactive websites that have given
designers a new platform to instantly
showcase their designs and
simultaneously sell their products
relying less on glossy photo spreads in
vogue
this season philip lim is all about
outerwear winter now shares the coveted
front row with new media
i guarantee you that anna will
change the game of digitized content
we're taking
branded content
with her voice to
millions of consumers that we couldn't
possibly touch
with a magazine as an exclusive medium
winter her colleagues and critics alike
believe has transcended the medium she
has become the curator of worldwide
fashion
[Applause]
[Music]
anna does something almost every day
that's huge
she always has an idea of pushing this
industry and sort of pushing it further
and further
this is a
multi-hundred billion dollar global
industry and that is a byproduct of many
things but one of them is anna's
stewardship of vogue magazine in 20 plus
year
she's got this incredible reference
point of what
good fashion is and what talent is and
what creativity is
she's not here just to say whether a
dress looks nice or not or whether a new
shoe is groovy enough
she's really there to encourage the
entire industry young talent established
talent these are all difficult balls to
keep in there but she feels that this is
her duty
this is her legacy as well
she is the woman that brought fashion
really
to big business
and to the world
globally
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he is the fashion world's reigning super
power whatever aspect of the business
that you're in in our industry everybody
looks at ralph lauren as the model a
dream maker who netted billions by
imagining what others wished for every
time i design clothes i'm making a movie
i don't think anybody since walt disney
has been as successful in persuading
millions and millions of people to buy
into his fantasies wherever you go ralph
lauren's brands project an aura of
rarefied living ralph's brand stands for
classic timeless fashion the brand
represents your souvenir of this
fabulous lifestyle that you want to be a
part of but his life was not as picture
perfect my sense was he thought that
would be the last time he walked the
wrong way it wasn't not by a long shot
we used to joke that he always had a
plan to take over the world he's taken
over the world there's no doubt about it
ralph lauren is the most famous one-man
brand on the planet a brand that is
synonymous with a superior lifestyle
ralph always knew that he wouldn't win
if he didn't take risks and he's always
pushing the envelope he keeps himself
awake at night he's worried that he's
going to fail he's obsessed
um he's brilliant he's irratible he's
difficult and he can also be kind and
interesting and sweet he's a huge bundle
of contradictions lauren insists that
the images he creates communicate his
story and did not participate in this
show
before he was ralph lauren he was ralph
lipschitz the youngest of four children
who wore his brother's hand-me-downs
born in 1939 to jewish immigrant working
class parents he grew up in the bronx
new york his father was a house painter
and amateur artist living with someone
for whom aesthetics mattered
would of course affect a child in that
household michael gross is the author of
genuine authentic the real life of ralph
lauren he went to yeshiva and he wore a
yarmulke and he wore all the other
paraphernalia of orthodox jews every
single day he told me that at the very
beginning when he was living in the
bronx he would go and escape to the
movie theater and literally fall into
the fantasies of the movies of that era
which was really you know one of the
great moviegoing eras the late 40s and
early 50s warren helstein is one of
lauren's boyhood friends we all as kids
looked at the movie screens and the
actors and how good they looked i know
ralph particularly liked fred astaire
and he truly did project himself into
the scenes in which men like gary cooper
and gary grant were playing he sees the
characters that populate his dreams and
his visions and that vision that ability
to step into a fantasy world ralph
brought to the fashion business
in one of his only two major television
interviews ever lauren told charlie rose
back in 1993 about the enduring impact
of those experiences i was very
influenced by movies
i was very influenced by
a world that had a sense of dream
that had a sense of something else and
what i was influenced in these places
was the good guy the the the the
hoppalong cassidy um
not the corny guy but the there was the
man on the white horse my sense was
i had an integrity inside me about what
i believed in
i i did it honestly
and
but i had a point of view i was very
strong warren helstein says that when
they were teenagers lauren asked
helstein's father a tailor to make him
one of his first suits but i remember
going down to my father's place with him
and it was very difficult
you know just said my father's dad do
whatever he likes
he says i can't please him i said okay
that's
that's it even though he was a
perfectionist lauren was a guy's guy he
liked basketball best i would say okay
we're all good
how are you in 2011 when oprah winfrey
came to interview him on his colorado
ranch lauren shared his earliest
ambitions did you always want to be a
cowboy i want to be a baseball player i
want to be basketball player i wanted to
be an actor i want to be a dancer
actually i wanted to be batman if you
don't that's the secret i'm telling you
and everyone out there
when he was in his late teens he and his
brother jerry opted for a name change as
ralph said to me the problem with the
name lipschitz is it had the word in it
and he endured endless teasing that
continued through school i'm sure into
the army i believe that ralph suggested
to me that the name lauren came from
lauren bacall who you know was a great
style icon as well as a great actress
following high school lauren worked as a
salesman while taking business classes
at night he never got a degree
in 1964
after a short stint in the army
twenty-six-year-old lauren married ricky
lowbeer a receptionist he met at a
doctor's office he married the girl who
would look perfect in the convertible
with her blonde hair flowing ricky
became his model his his backstop ricky
was always i think in the back of his
mind
[Music]
still looking for his place in the world
lauren set his sights on new york's
fashion industry he became a salesman
for brooks brothers and then a series of
necktie manufacturers i took him to his
first polo match at blindbrook
where we were
exposed to fabulous things
the silver the leather the horses the
tall slinky blondes
big hats and just the high society that
we really weren't uh knowledgeable of
but certainly
it didn't take us a moment to appreciate
it that fabulous world transformed
lauren's vision he called me up and said
he was going to open up his own business
and what was my opinion about the name
and he said he had it down to players
or polo and i said ralph
polo is totally elitist
hardly anybody knows anything about it
but everybody plays something so there's
no choice it's got to be players he said
okay thanks a lot
goodbye and then
the rest is history
it was the era of plain narrow ties when
lauren offered up a radical design
concept
colorful wide ties
striking out on his own one of his first
stops bloomingdale's
marvin traub was the former ceo and
president of bloomingdale's shortly
before he died he spoke about the brash
young designer he showed them to the
bloomingdale tie buyer who said i like
them i'll buy them but i don't want that
ralph lauren label on it i want a
bloomingdale label
now here's ralph starting and struggling
in business about to get an order from
bloomingdale's he closed the sample case
and said i will not accept the order
without my name
[Music]
several months after ralph lauren walked
away from an offer at bloomingdale's the
renowned store called him back i thought
the ties were terrific and if he wanted
his name on it that was fine because i
felt the ties would sell and they did
other well-known names in men's clothing
also wanted in including paul stewart
and neiman marcus
within a year lawrence sold a whopping
half million dollars of ties
the designer had designs on something
even bigger to expand his brand
he aimed to do so he told charlie rose
by envisioning clothing that he himself
would want to wear what you thought you
can buy in england what you thought cary
grant was wearing in fred astaire you
could not walk into a store and buy when
i came along
the business was not at all like the
things that i made you could not buy you
couldn't find it bloomingdale's saw
potential and profit in lauren's line we
worked closely from the ties to men's
shirts to suits sport coats slacks the
total men's collection and then he came
and said marvin i'd like to do a women's
business i think the most important
break for ralph lauren was probably
getting a boutique of his own in
bloomingdale's it was the moment when
someone outside of ralph's fantasy
existence
agreed with him and brought him into the
world of commerce
this was the first time that
bloomingdale's had given a designer his
own in-store boutique and the business
grew very rapidly
ralph as in everything else
knew exactly what he wanted in the shop
what he wanted on the floors what he
wanted on the walls it created really a
ralph lauren environment and it's all
ralph's dream menswear designer john
varvatos was a protege of lauren's if
you go back into the 60s and 70s people
put things on a mannequin they never
told stories ralph took you into a
fantasy world ralph took you to an
island he took you to the hamptons he
took you to the west
three years after his first ties went on
sale lauren won the oscar of the fashion
industry the 1970 cody award for his
menswear line and in 1971 lauren bought
the first of what would be many luxury
cars pulitzer prize architecture and
design critic paul goldberger has
reported on ralph lauren's famous car
collection i think it was a mercedes
convertible that he couldn't quite
afford at that point he bought anyway
because he
understands that very kind of
aspirational reach that he's trying to
sell to other people he reached back to
his earlier fantasy that polo match
and introduced his signature emblem the
polo player
but despite strong sales the company
found itself in financial trouble
to keep it going lauren was forced to
invest most of his personal savings one
hundred thousand dollars he also hired a
new business partner retail executive
peter strom who pitched in and bought 10
percent of the business for six thousand
dollars i think he was very worried they
were delivering everything like their
distribution pattern was all wrong we
solved those problems and we got the
right stores to buy the right amount of
things to display everything properly
two years after strom's arrival and back
on track lauren's brand got a boost when
his men's clothes were cast in the great
gatsby his ability to create clothes
that looked like costumes that looked
like clothes that looked like costumes
was unequaled in american fashion hi
hi but i actually think that the claim
that he designed annie hall was more
important the annie hall look would
inspire one of lauren's earliest women's
collections and the designer himself was
often the featured model in his brand's
ad campaigns commercial director jeff
madoff has shot many of ralph lauren's
fashion shows he wears this stuff so
he's become the embodiment of what he
creates like frank perdue with his
chickens
you know ralph in his clothes there was
an authenticity to it
the company launched a blitz of new
collections including a wide-ranging
home collection
lauren also licensed his name to other
products trading a measure of control
for capital
now flush with cash in 1986 ralph lauren
went all in
spending 30 million dollars to open a
stand-alone flagship store housed in new
york city's historic rhinelander mansion
my wife and i were there opening day at
two o'clock in the afternoon
and i said the store was packed with
people i said ralph how are you doing he
said i think i'm doing all right and i
said ralph you're a retailer you can
ring off the cash register now and the
manager
came back and said we have forty one
thousand dollars in and ralph said is
that good
and i said that's very good then i went
back to my office and the phone rings
about 5 30 and it's ralph marvin we have
a hundred and one thousand dollars and
how is that and i said it was terrific
this was ralph learning to be a retailer
i think it told his story to the world
anybody who came to new york it's like
on the tour guide of new york you know
you understand ralph lauren's message
very clearly when you go through there
when you walk by those windows you get
it as the business continued to grow
lauren pushed his employees harder than
ever there's a vast team of designers
and creative executives
they do the designing they do just about
everything but they bring it to ralph
and finally
it's ralph who decides and there are
actually this amazing thing little tiny
stickers that get put up on idea boards
and they say rl likes
and in that act
ralph lauren takes possession of those
clothes of those designs and deserves
the credit ralph pays more attention to
detail than anybody i've ever met in my
life and
when he is designing
and he's looking at the clothes
he'll look and
want a lapel ever so much more peaked or
ever so much narrower or he likes the
plaid but he wants it to be bigger
in 1986 the estimated worth of the
privately held company was 600 million
dollars and lauren not his models was
the cover shot it would seem that life
couldn't get any better for lauren when
he launched his next women's collection
but behind the scenes something very
alarming was shaking up the fame
designer we were top of their saint
regis hotel
and
the finale of the show
ralph came out
and i saw his face unlike i had seen it
before
and i was fighting back tears
i started crying there was something
going on i didn't even know what it was
it was just visceral
no one but those closest to him knew
that lauren had been diagnosed with a
brain tumor
it was one of those things that you just
didn't want to believe
couldn't happen to ralph what did it
mean for the future there was all those
questions at the time
[Music]
as i was riding home in the taxi and i
heard on the news reports that designer
ralph lauren was being admitted for
emergency brain surgery
wow
oh yeah my god
sure i worried
i felt so bad for him
you know
fortunately the tumor was benign
after surgery there was a long road
ahead and new priorities oh i don't
think he worried
about what would happen to the business
i think he
worried about living about his life
lawrence shared his ordeal with charlie
rose i remember when i came home from
the hospital
and
i took a walk in central park and i was
very weak
and i saw some guys running in the park
running and sweating i said to myself
i want to do that
several weeks later lauren returned to
work i think he came back even more
aggressive than ever but i think he was
a little bit more relaxed
a little bit more laid back and maybe
was valuing every moment a little bit
more
he launched a fitness wear collection
and created a top selling perfume
he spent millions promoting these lines
and the product universe surrounding
them
james fallon editor of women's wear
daily calls ralph lauren a powerhouse in
the magazine world because he's one of
the biggest advertisers out there if i
launch my fragrance and i take an ad out
and or a series of ads you're going to
then do a profile of me i mean look at
the number of magazines
that did put him on the cover when he
had his 40th anniversary and that
reflects the extent to which they
appreciated his financial support in
past years appreciated and also depended
on it a 200 million dollar annual
advertising budget
is an 800 pound gorilla ralph lauren
sits wherever he wants and if that's the
cover of your magazine
ralph's going to be there
lauren's dominance was also evident when
audrey hepburn presented him with the
council of american fashion designers
lifetime achievement award there was one
of his muses his icons audrey hepburn
the woman that he watched when he was a
little kid in the movies
now handing him this statue that for him
could have been the oscar
remember the princess
i got her
with the launch of lauren's upscale
purple label in 1994 the company looked
great to the untrained eye after all
sales were at an all-time high but that
only told half the story
heatha prabhakar is a retail business
journalist like every retailer that has
big dreams it just grew too quickly
there was a lot of capital expended in
order to make that brand where he wanted
to be that combined with a very
lackluster operations in terms of
distribution created really a perfect
storm for a company that was almost on
the brink of bankruptcy lauren needed a
lifeline and found it with goldman sachs
the investment firm purchased 28 of polo
ralph lauren for 135 million dollars
that was surprising to us because we
never realized that he had been that
close to the you know back to the wall
financially and i think that's sort of
what led to the goldman sachs investment
they're very good about identifying
where the growth is and what's going to
be a company that's going to have
long-term growth and that's exactly what
they saw in ralph lauren and the
infusion of cash meant exponential
growth
with polo ralph lauren opening new
stores and overhauling older ones by
1997 ralph lauren was the top selling
designer in the world consumers spent
almost five billion dollars a year on
his products
goldman sachs saw greater potential and
pressed lauren to go public he wasn't so
sure he always had concerns that once it
was a public company
he would have less freedom of action
that it was no longer his own brand
because he had shareholders and a board
to deal with
despite his initial reservations ralph
lauren decided to take his company
public in june 1997.
liz dunn a retail analyst at mcquarrie
capital has been tracking lauren's
company for years part of the challenge
with going public is that investors want
to see growth quarter to quarter
year to year in a very consistent linear
fashion and so i think in the early days
of the company's history as a public
company they sort of struggled with that
when he first went public we would cover
his annual meetings and he would stand
in front of a shareholders going wall
street doesn't understand me our shares
are just sitting there they don't really
move i wish they would get what we do
lauren was now working to satisfy his
shareholders the company began to sell
in more stores but sales growth slowed
and profit margins declined
and 16 months after its opening day high
of 33 dollars a share it fell below 17
i know that it tormented him we talked
about it
he talked about it he was frustrated
that wall street couldn't see
what was abundantly clear to him and
always had been since 1967
that he was it but he was the guy it
drove him crazy
um and it was into that environment that
came a man named roger farah who was one
of the great retail executives in
america roger farah came over and really
restructured the unsexy parts of the
business supply chain operations one
thing he also did too was that he bought
back those licenses he brought those
brands back in-house and made sure that
all those brands were underneath the
ralph lauren umbrella they're going
through a tremendous growth period
and i had suggested that we put together
something that really codify the polo
brand message
and we called it ralph lauren philosophy
it's a brand video that lauren
commissioned the way i do collections
what inspires me is a story or a theme
that gets to me that says i know how to
build this i don't build a collection
from a sleeve or from a specific fabric
i build it out of a dream control to him
is very important and this was a way to
present a unified message where he
didn't have to be there but it was like
he was there
lauren continued to expand with an eye
on international sales he opened
flagship stores in milan
tokyo
and even moscow
america is represented in france by
mcdonald's and ralph lauren i mean you
know which one makes our culture look
better in paris i think the ralph lauren
store it's really become a kind of
symbolic american embassy but in the
summer of 2012 the all-american designer
was attacked when news reports revealed
that the team usa uniforms lauren
designed were not made in the usa made
in china this is china china i think
they should take all the uniforms put
them in a big pile and burn them the
company said the uniforms for the 2014
winter games would be produced in the
united states
throughout his career ralph lauren has
carefully cultivated his own image he
has homes on fifth avenue in jamaica
long island and bedford new york as well
as a seventeen 000 acre ranch in
colorado where he spends time with his
wife and three grown children he also
spends time and lots of money on his pet
passion cars are fun and toys and they
all offer you a different experience to
me they work so hard this 2010
promotional video announces a paris
exhibit of some of lauren's 60-plus
vintage cars he once told me his car
collection is something he does
first because he just loves cars and
responds to them and he doesn't collect
art
unlike most people in his income bracket
he said you know you can't drive a
painting and he loves the idea of being
able to take any of his cars and drive
it around on a sunday afternoon say paul
goldberger says that lauren has changed
some of the car's original colors he
sort of looks at something and says
this is wonderful and exciting and
beautiful but it actually could be even
better and i want to make it even more
perfect for 40 years ralph lauren's
pursuit of perfection has kept him
firmly in charge as ceo and chairman of
the board of the company that wears his
name i think that that you know small
symbol of the polo pony is is enduring
and it's something that customers over a
long period of time have chosen this is
probably the best long-term story in my
coverage because there are these variety
of growth opportunities that are really
driving a doubling or more of sales over
the next several years the former thai
salesman at age 72 is one of the world's
wealthiest people worth seven and a half
billion dollars
i think that the last piece of ralph
lipschitz that remains in ralph lauren
is a kernel of insecurity and it is the
fuel that runs the engine that runs the
person who personifies the brand ralph
doesn't sit on his laurels for one
minute not for one minute i mean you can
enjoy the moment but you have to
understand that you have to keep things
going and you can't be a one-trick pony
speaking of ponies
it's not one of the most important but
it's never on sale
and how much is that
14.90
[Music]
this one should be 26.50 these are ready
and are around 3 500.
um
around 4 000 at most it's calfskin with
embroidery otherwise there's python skin
ranging from 3000 to 5000
[Music]
how about this crocodile skin bag
it's the ultimate precious bag and
that's 29.
29 000 euros
[Music]
luxury designers famous worldwide aren't
feeling the economic squeeze
and in the fashion capsule people crowd
in even on a normal weekday afternoon
our journey starts in the temple of
milan's designer labels the fashion
district the queen of via montenegro
the identity of this brand is based on
the craftsmanship of the florentine
masters and the leather goods are its
prestige sector the same goes for potaka
veneta recalling the plating of the
leather goods manufacturers from vicenza
italian labels owned by the french and
together with ysl and other caring group
labels are invoicing in switzerland
[Music]
how much are these
1580
today we did all kinds of brands louis
putin
foreign mainly we did a lot of jimmy
choo
pateka veneta se loyan as well
what have you manufactured recently
high boots they gave me 40.
[Music]
are they from the latest winter
collection
is always asking for boots or sandals
many do they give you
every day about 100 pairs but they're
complicated
just gucci every day 100 pairs
the man we talk to is a subcontractor
and inside this workshop the luxury
shoes are made
the designer design the model makers do
prototypes but the big fashion house
turned to high level firms which
assigned the job to subcontractors the
craftsman for the actual production
our first stop to find out who is suing
the luxury bags and shoes is riveria
the shoe industry center of excellence
italy's flagship
the shoemaker's store advised us to come
here they said you make shoe uppers
of this model
the upper is the visible part of the
shoe
sewing it is the most important
manufacturing step in shoe making
the chinese specialize in this
production
[Music]
how much do they pay you for this
to talk about prices he makes us move
away from the work benches because the
amount he gets from the supplier is not
the same of what he pays to the worker
who is suing the shoes
we get 23 for this
i told the worker let's say that i give
four to them and six to me we usually
set the prices this way with ferragamo
the prices goes higher
how many can they make
every day 25 pairs
you pay them by the shoe
they keep working day and night so they
can make more
if you're saying that we're not
legitimate almost all the chinese work
this way it's useless to tell us that we
are not legitimate
payments by pair of shoes and piece work
is illegal if the shoe factory gives the
chinese 23 euros the worker is paid 4
euros to make a pair of boots and it's a
model by ferragamo of the current
collection
they're from the latest runway show
you're counting a lot on these boots
this year how much are they
15.50
is it the difficulty of this production
deciding the price
yes that's because our shoes are still
almost entirely handmade
these are made in florence
our headquarters are in florence we make
them here
this also justifies the price
supervisor came to the workshop to check
i'll show you one model
this model with the circles and ankle
strap this model has been around for two
years
would you like to try them on
how much are they
6.75
[Music]
we are talking about the tribute sandal
an iconic model by ysl worn on the red
carpet by adriana lima kaylee minnow
jennifer lopez julia roberts beyonce
they pay you nine euros a pair how many
pairs
for ten thousand nine euros just for the
upper and another four euros for the
coating
how much would a legitimate italian
craftsman cost
a lot probably
given that since 2000 150 local upper
manufacturers closed down and 300 new
chinese workshop opened at that time
we met on the condition of an amenity a
subcontractor manufacturer who had
always sewn designer shoes
the gucci boot i showed you is sold
between 300 to 1800 euros
for that gucci boot they gave me 60
euros
the brand pays 180 to the shoe
manufacturers that gives me the job
that's 10
that's why they don't want people to
know that the actual cost of the luxury
shoes materials and manufacturer is 10
to 15
at the most of the final price
all-inclusive
assembly general expenses box everything
of that 10 paid by the brand the
manufacturers represent a cost between
40 and 60
it also depends on the type of
manufacturer and the type of shoe
the court shoes will take 22 minutes to
make for a gucci court shoe they will
give me 9 euros
the cost of a craftsman is calculated
per minute but the processing time may
vary between 20 minutes and four hours
depending on the shoe
it's the labor costs the cost of those
who make the shoes that will get lower
they will strangle you on labor costs
because the chinese will cut them by
half
how can they ask for half of the
production costs because instead of
eight hours they'll double their working
hour or they get paid under the table
they are boycotting us on hourly rates
if i'm legitimate i cannot ask for less
than 18 to 20 euros per hour
they keep asking to lower our prices and
we the subcontractors feel trapped
indeed for the ysl sandal the legitimate
manufacturer cost would be around 30
euros the chinese told us he gets 9
euros plus 4 euros for the coding and
that's less than half
we brought a shoe upper whose
manufacturing cost was estimated at 30
euros in one day this price has
considerably lowered
only for the shoe upper i should decided
15 is fine yes 15.
how much for this
good you can do it right
if i do it as for the luxury brand eight
euros
on the international level there isn't a
law forcing fashion house to control
their production chain
at the moment only gucci has pledged its
social responsibility with the ethical
certification sa8000
this means ensuring the customer and
improving the company's reputation that
their products were made respecting the
rights of the workers across the entire
chain of suppliers and subcontractors
in recent years some of the caring group
brands have been more careful regarding
the production
someone from the upper management wants
to check what happens then
the show factory gives us some of the
shoes in small quantities so they can
come to us for their inspection and show
they are working with good craftsmen
we are only a front
but then the big quantities go to the
chinese
who's to blame if the prices are too low
the brand names at the head of the chain
or those who subcontract
the shoe factory is signing a contract
with the main office
it's hard to determine the legal
responsibilities without the
transparency of the production chain
this way as long as sweated labor is
concerned
the company can just shrug and say i
knew nothing about it
there is a connivance of the brands in
this because they are the ones imposing
the prices the factories must work for
it is no longer the factories making a
quote and proposing it but it's the main
office that will impose a production
rate then the factory will have to
recoup within the production chain it's
their problem
we're talking about a product that has
such a high markup that all the workers
could make a good living
we were asking for more transparency in
the production chain then again it takes
two to reach an agreement
they never approved it
our proposals were never accepted
[Music]
they said the factory had closed down
but it kept working the chinese are
still there and they never take a
vacation
the dismissal was motivated by the
termination of the company
i was also told saturday he'll work for
eight hours for free i refused
right away to threaten me they fired a
worker
we want to work it's our right to work
legally
we are in the center of florence a group
of 13 senegalese workers is
demonstrating in front of the building
of regional tuscany
their contract was not renewed after
they asked to legalize their working
positions
the company in question is poseta a
chinese-run firm specialized in
metalwork
but not of any metal work
we are talking about the designer
buckles of luxury brands
the firm gets worked directly from the
first level right in front of them
our firm is here
with that red gate in the back there is
polzetta workshop
and offices right here in front of us
that's right
what happens after all the original
buckles arrived
we work on them and they go back where
they came from
how many items a day are you working on
one day i did 3 350 items they were
buckled for bags
abdul's task is lathering
it means staying for hours bent over a
tub polishing the buckles for designer
bags and shoes
and it's a very hard job
we did a lot of different brands
prada gucci
giorgio armani
[Music]
i work 11 hours monday through friday
on saturday i give them six hours
nobody pays me for them
the word gift was used by them
that's what they're telling you
gift me or i'll send you away from the
chinese law rules
[Music]
but not only a gifting system of
overtime was in place
part of the paycheck about 200 euros a
month was given back under the table
they take everything away from you
but a regular contract stays in place
you have to give them back the cash
for instance when you go to the bank
it looks as though they duly paid you
everything then you have to go get that
money and give it back to them
you get to the atm and get the money if
you do it they renew your contract and
if you don't they send you away
this is called extortion but this way
your paycheck is clean
i'd like to talk to the owner of
positive if i may
he doesn't want to do the interview
could i talk to mr bingzi
there is no one by the name
isn't he the owner of one of these three
firms i don't know goodbye
we are here on the premise of the same
firm that was closed down and formerly
had another name
only the minority of the saint release
workers was brave enough to turn to the
labor unions
no complaint ever came from 100 or so
chinese workers
the chinese know about the firm and
their home they don't care about
anything else
they hire chinese people husbands and
wives they took work 13 hours a day
how do they chinese live do they sleep
there in the parking lot
do they sleep in the car
that's where they live
producing in florence has an added value
the tuscan territory has a great
manufacturing tradition regarding both
leather and metalwork
so much so that gucci made that is forte
in an advertising campaign
instead of bringing the work to china
they brought the chinese here they
reversed the course
it's no coincidence if the issue after
taking to the streets involving the
government and especially the newspapers
subsided with the reinstatement of the
dismissed workers
nevertheless these are the luxury
workers and these are their
but the homes that the production
workers come out of the woodwork to
assert their rights is an exception
especially where jobs are scarce
naples is our last stop it's one of the
most important italian leather districts
the napoleon craftsmanship tradition is
famous worldwide
for which brands did you experience the
worst conditions
gucci
gucci was too much
fendi
too much referred to the conditions
they make you sign a three-hour contract
they pay you very little when they want
to and how they want to a contract for
three hours
three hours a day
and how long did you work eight hours or
even longer
what about the wage
real low 30 euros a day
the final paycheck
500 600
you 4700 did gucci
for gucci for five years in this field
i've been working for 25 years
how old were you when you started 12 13.
in 25 years working as a dire at
subcontractor factories the worker
talking to us dyed the leather of bags
and purses for major fashion houses
his testimony courageous for accepting
to tell us is only an example of a
situation labor unions describe as
desperate
but when a factory has dozens of
three-hour contracts
how can nobody suspect that it might be
sweated labor
i just cannot believe that the main
office has no idea of such a situation
when the size of the phenomenon of
sweated labor of underpayment lack of
rights is so huge that it covers the
vast majority of luxury workers
it's impossible not to know they could
tell me it's none of my business i gave
them work
it's the factories who are responsible
i'm washing my hands of it
we are in the outer northern outskirts
of naples beyond scampia and second
digliano around cassandrino arazano
casoria all neighboring municipalities
the leather factories are gathered most
of them aren't direct suppliers but
subcontractors where you may find the
most difficult situations this one in
via paulo barcelino is the most visible
built up area the rest of the factories
are hard to detect
most of the factories around here are
like this yellow one here it is simply
the ground floor of the houses where
someone else live just go inside the
courtyard and you'll see on the ground
floor instead of a garage there's a
small leather goods shoes or even
clothing factory
we find factories who only work
illegally they are not registered they
almost don't exist
but in this case as well we're talking
about thousands of workers
in this area it's hard to find factories
where workers earn at least a minimum
wage it's a rarity when you do find one
when the gucci inspectors were expected
they said they will be here tomorrow
clean up the factory
and the gucci inspectors would come
yes but two days before we were notified
that the inspectors would come we
obviously had to wear our coats ear
protectors goggles the factory was so
clean as we could only dream for the
rest of the time
as soon as they left everything turned
back as it was
did they ever ask you anything
they weren't going to ask the workers
directly how much do you make a day how
many hours are you working
on
the situation is out of control that we
are stricken by one story in particular
where they make counterfeit items a
business notoriously in the hands of the
organized crime sometimes they also
receive the real stuff there was a
seized workshop we worked inside i
didn't know the name of my employer he
used to call us with a disposable cell
phone
excuse me what is your name
what's it to you
he used to pay us in his car he'd take
the money from an envelope or a box on
the back seat
we used to make counterfeit items
but you did realize you were also making
the real stuff
sometimes we did
how could you tell
a little tab inside was missing from the
counterfeit
the manufacturing was identical
identical same material same stitching
same color same manufacturing
didn't they tell you make them better
no they were just the same
how long did you work
four five months
and they still owe 100 euro the
counterfeit was better
[Laughter]
this is the absurdity of it all
we're talking about products of
incredible value
but those who make them are treated
under third world conditions
when i am accusing a company for the
transparency of its supply chain and the
wages because i'm suspecting they are
low but i don't know for sure i am
accusing it because they are doing all
they can do to save money
and they are jeopardizing the factories
they hired because if the factory owners
hardly scrape by there's nothing they
can do
you are jeopardizing the worker as well
they're putting money before anything
else even before people's dignity if
that's not a problem
you